speaking of MMA fighters and choking
people out speaking of so like the nerd
I am we're in Carmel and I'm just
looking up random I forgot what
motivated me to do this but I'm on
YouTube watching now my latest thing is
going and watching replays of random ass
like racing Styles okay like I recently
discovered um sidecar Motocross okay
like motocross bikes with a side car oh
yeah yeah okay I think I've seen that
maybe not like dirt bikes yeah dude dirt
bikes with a side car do they do they go
off like two play it it's the weirdest
[__] dude dude what are you watching
this [__] is violent bro is there
someone in the side yes
bro wait
what what could possibly are these kids
no no
no oh that's sick though yeah yeah oh my
God that's awesome okay I get it now
look up uh look up Isle of Man
sidecar is of man yeah clip that please
yeah look up I I already said I'm I play
Counter-Strike and I'm gay so true
true yeah I'm just this is so dumb I'm
just picturing a gay club and it's like
all gay dudes and then a land Center in
there it's just mutually agreed upon
that Counter-Strike players are like
they're not gay but they have like a g
pass it's like you hear
you here to dance or you here to game I
hear to game come on in boys
yeah that's
good so
anyway uh what is this this is this is
is of man which is like the scariest
race this is I love man this is I love
man gotcha you love what I of men okay
got it yeah every year there's aisle of
men and this is one of the scary ious
championships in all of Motorsport
history these dudes do this sidecar [__]
at like 150 mph Jesus Christ how do you
even train to be that guy in the back um
I think maybe a Pummel horse yeah it's
like yeah and this is another uh
depressing thing someone dies every year
at this event
good they kill themselves yeah uh that's
essentially what this is it is a Death
Wish no Before the Race even starts oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah pull up I love man
pull up I love man pull up I love man
pull up I love man on board these guys
are living in Fast Forward wait what
where's the uh this is this is another
event like they have multiple styles of
races on the day but I think this is the
big Main
Event um there are guys in their 50s
racing this dude how fast are they going
down that probably [__] Buck 50 Buck
70 look look at the points of reference
like just try to pick something and then
count it's not even a second yeah let me
try and count ready
one that's all I got that's all I can
get oh yeah okay I got one oh anyway so
there's this uh there's this
organization called nitr cross and they
have something called Baja Bugs dude no
hold on just just listen how many
[__] weird races did you find there's
so and uh there basically you know
they're just like VW bugs that can go
off-roading
and you know cowboy Cerrone the MMA
fighter yeah I I'm just watching this
random clip and they're like and we got
Donald cowboy Cerrone in the number 27
car and I go what the
[__] cuz he's retired okay and I go you
this what he does now that's part of
what he does and you just found that
randomly just randomly yeah what's the
race called look look it up nitr cross
Baja Bug I'm man names too I'm a wealth
of I love man Baja Bug yeah I love man
Baja Bug what what is this race though
like what do they do it's kind of scary
no if you just look it on look it up on
YouTube like the particular track they
did they do this massive jump into the
course to like kind of get the uh
momentum going so Blake wil got the win
yesterday hung out with him in the pool
with him at the pool some adult liti and
I'd be I'd be [__] it a little bit
on that so these are little VW bugs if
you're listening that are like I am
assuming soup the [__] up and they're on
like a dirt course yeah they're not that
fast but they're
quick yeah and then Cowboys back there
in one of the yellow ones what the [__]
yeah I kind of want one of these cars
yeah you can get one a little vdub bug
with off-road capability or you just
want one just just noral drive down the
streets you know normal yeah
a vintage bug mhm did and did they get
air or anything um they can but anyway
yeah so you know I was just laughing at
I pull up this random ass video and like
what the Donald cowboy Cerrone he's
number four you're like damn I need
cooler Hobbies yeah that's what I'd be
thinking yeah the [__] am I doing
running yeah this is way
cooler you know well and then I started
I started piecing together if I could
put together like a there's also man oh
I don't I sounds cool right
now uh tractor demolition
Derby's oh lawn mower demolition deries
okay so dudes buy like the ones that you
could drive like for your lawn and then
they they put go-kart engines in them
and they like put steel around them and
that's cool yeah I was theorizing how
much it would cost if I bought five and
I tried to hold my own uh lawn mower Dem
battle bot style yeah but you're [__]
they like drive into into each other
yeah yeah you're trying to beat each
other's [__] up at I love man you're
trying to beat each other's [__]
up in the lawn mower demolition derby
competition dude this is just redneck
go-karts it is
but Derby Dave cam yeah that's that's
Derby Dave right there I wonder if he
knows House of gourd
ah House of yeah
there's so many different styles of this
but I want there was one where there was
a straightup eight-year-old competing
with grown men and he you know he was a
little [__] so when he'd get hit he'd go
flying out the card a little bit and it
just made me wonder how much this hurts
or if it actually hurts oh it probably
definitely hurts for sure can I do one
more what there's a clip look of um
go-kart lawn mower ah I don't know how
many views it has but it's this big is
this big boy getting into his brand new
like souped up lawn
mower God damn it the the moment where
he fires it up and he takes off you've
never seen 250 lbs move so fast I'll
look it up during the break dude it's so
funny okay we're watching it in the
bonus yeah damn you going some crazy
rabbit holes yeah man how long like that
I feel like this would take you a long
time to I'm a crackhead man it takes me
10 minutes yeah you do this like you're
watching porn I can't dude 20 tabs open
oh yeah yeah yeah I can't make a normal
YouTube video to save my life at this
point don't even get me started man I
did a whole like deep dive on New Age
spirituality okay oh [__]
man